Swedish parliamentary candidate has
claimed that he was attacked by a
migrant at an alternative for Sweden
party rally in a town in the west of the
country tensions flared during
campaigning for a general election that
seen a surge in support for Euroskeptic
right-wing parties and next is maria for
national report says this afternoon that
country is also seeing a spike in crime
levels - we've gotten used to pictures
of shootings and car burnings from
Sweden so-called vulnerable
neighborhoods but the upcoming Swedish
elections has brought violence to an
everyday street one of my colleagues
from alternative for Sweden being
attacked by an immigrant youth who
attended the meeting and was screaming
and shouting all all over the meeting I
was attacked - I tried to protect my
friend and colleague and this immigrant
starting hitting both of us in the face
also they threw eggs at our vehicle when
we left the scene they ran after and
when we had to stop in at the red light
they kicked the car Swedish police never
confirmed the attackers ethnicity that
the party member referred to him as an
immigrant but that is not all they blame
immigrants for an overall high
criminality rate and low security across
the country although the connection was
never established officially the
alternative the party offers to Sweden
is sealed borders and immigrants sent
back to where they came from
repatriation instead of immigration they
say and also a tougher police and a
stronger army the meeting gathered some
supporters that the majority came to
voice their discontent because he was
saying that we need to clean Sweden
though we need to get every four and
they're out of here and Sweden need to
be united like back in the old days
not really because if you look back in
time sweetness always taking for endures
so if we didn't taking new people its
wouldn't work we are racist on our
streets we are racist on our streets
party is saying they want to take down
all the immigrants and the people is
unhappy they don't liked it as long as
we can integrate them to Swedish society
and they become they become as Swedish
as me because I'm also an immigrant from
Belgium as long as they become Swedish
and they work and they do normal Swedish
things it's absolutely no problem as
long as they can keep their religion
they can keep their culture but they
should speak Swedish and they should
work yeah many immigrants here feel like
there they are not included in the
society police told us they are always
invited to meetings like this one many
parties have a lot of meetings now and
some parties
I thought EFS area they have a lot of
people that like don't like the opinions
that's why we call the police it's
always like this when it's designed to
Elections Sweden will hold a general
election in just 10 days
tensions are high ahead of the national
vote that could be historic they're
ruling left-wing Social Democrats the
oldest and largest party in Sweden could
see its worst result in the last 100
years as right-wing ideas are gaining
more and more popularity brief notion
arty from Sweden
you